J'ai
vu le ciel
devenir
rouge J'ai perdu quelqu'un il y a des années maintenant je le
cherche le
monde
dois-je continuer à
essayer Je ne suis pas
nul J'y arrive Je rentre à
la maison
[Musique]
passion ça a été tellement  Longtemps ton téléphone tu
sais ce qu'il dit les Japonais croient un
peu
plus longtemps que c'est l'armée la plus puissante
de la planète oui pourquoi
penses-tu que je vais accepter
tout ça parce que tout ne
change pas, brûle
tout  encore une fois
SC, nous sommes la dernière Lumière du monde,
vous devez savoir que ce n'est pas la
réponse, cela doit
finir, ce n'est pas tout, vous ne pouvez pas
choisir pour le monde, vous ne pouvez pas
choisir pour moi, c'est tout.  Je suis parti,
c'est tout ce qu'il te reste aussi, elle n'est pas
partie, il
doit y avoir un sacrifice, c'est brisé. Le
monde sh B
ensemble, nous pouvons
tout faire sauf
tout brûler à
nouveau.